Jean-Jacques Rousseau’s philosophy
of education is based on the idea
that children should develop a strong,
virtuous character, the ability to reason,
and a refined sense of sentiment. This is so that,
as adults, they are able to resist temptations,
think for themselves, and learn to
appreciate the finer things in life.
To explain his ideas, Rousseau wrote “Emile, or
On Education”. The book tells the story of a boy,
who goes through childhood, boyhood,
preadolescence, adolescence and adulthood.
All five stages happen under the
guardianship of his parents and a tutor.
Stage 1, early childhood, begins with Émile’s
birth. During this stage, it is essential for his
parents to ensure that Émile develops physically.
Only the mother should feed the boy, because
she naturally loves him more than anyone else.
To allow the boy to make experiences with all his
senses, he wears loose clothing and is placed in
a large cradle where he can move freely. Rousseau,
who was influenced by John Locke, believed that
dressing children too warmly makes them weak.
If Emile doesn’t want to eat, he’s supported. If
he wants to use his left hand, he can. Beating
or shouting at the boy should be avoided.
When Emile “cries”, which Rousseau called
our first language, his mother should try to
understand him and find the underlying cause.
Since children are born essentially
good, it is the responsibility of the
parents to shield them from those who
could influence their innocent minds.
During Stage 2, Boyhood, Emile is educated to
perfect his senses. This is important because
the mind needs a wide range of trained senses
to perceive information correctly and develop
good judgment. Instead of recommending books, the
tutor lets Emile play games and conduct natural
experiments outside. The city or a school are
not the right places for a child at this age.
Emile learns to tell right from wrong
by experiencing the consequences of his
actions. Instead of actively teaching,
the tutor is merely a bystander who is
there to protect the boy from those
who want to influence his thinking or
teach him bad habits. Over time Emile
learns morality and virtue naturally.
In Stage 3, Preadolescence, Emile
is ready to learn how to reason.
Rousseau thought that only self-directed
learning led to the discipline necessary
to acquire real knowledge.
The tutor therefore trusts
Emile's interests and if the boy wants
to learn history, history he learns.
Languages are acquired
naturally through conversations.
Emile is also taught carpentry, a manual
labor that requires creativity and intellect,
which helps him to become a virtuous adult who
knows the value of hard work. Doing such work
also keeps Emile out of trouble, and allows him to
make a living in the event of a change in fortune.
In Stage IV, Adolescence, Emile is ready for
the last part of his education — sentiment.
Only now is he capable of understanding
complex emotions such as true compassion.
Emile now becomes a loving person who learns to
live with, and for others. Or as Rousseau wrote
"We have made an active and thinking being. It
remains for us, in order to complete the man,
only to make a loving and feeling being—that
is to say, to perfect reason by sentiment"
The tutor now begins formal education
and introduces the passionate boy to
concepts such as religion. Children
who learn such complex ideas earlier,
are unable to think about them freely and hence
just recite what they have been told. Emile,
whose character has grown strong enough to reason,
is now permitted to mingle with people in society.
In Stage V, Adulthood, Emile becomes a
virtuous man, who can make up his own mind.
He visits the city and develops a
sense for the finer things in life.
Thanks to his strong character,
the pursuit of wealth or other
temptations are none of his interest.
The young man is now ready to meet Sophie
— the perfect woman, his wife-to-be.
Sophie, a representative of the ideal
woman, is educated to be governed by her
husband while Émile, a representative of the
ideal man, is educated to be self-governing.
“The man should be strong and active; the woman
should be weak and passive”’, Rousseau wrote.
Sophie’s purpose is to please,
advise and console her husband.
Once published, Rousseau’s books were widely
criticized, burned, and banned. The Church and
state issued a warrant for Rousseau's arrest.
In addition, modern women disagreed with his
ideas or saw in him a hypocrite: Rousseau himself
sent away all five of his children to orphanages.
Nevertheless, “Emile” became Rousseau’s most
important work and a pillar of modern education.
But what are your thoughts? Do you think Emile
receives the ideal education to become a truly
free thinking mind? Is it right to try to
protect children from society's influence?
Or was Rousseau wrong about education? Tell
us what you think in the comments below.
If you found this helpful, check
out our other videos and subscribe.
If you want to support our work,
join us on patreon.com/sprouts.
For more information and additional
contents, visit sproutsschools.com